what do you think about the um these
things that I'm using Sony a74 great
it's great see yeah it's uh I've uh I've
been you know I Googled around just
trying to find a camera that can do
video and photography pretty well and
obviously going was just like generic
lenses Prime I've resisted everything my
whole journey with these camera thing
I'm trying to figure stuff out is like
prime lenses seems so stupid so the
problem is it's like a fixed Zoom thing
yep it's like why
because I remember I was going to like
Ukraine
and thinking it's similar like uh
um yeah very similar to space flight but
you're very constrained because you're
going into an unknown environment you go
into a war zone you go into a front you
don't know what like you don't know
anything right and there's like a little
suitcase you have to like see figure out
like how do you film this what's what's
robust
um what gives you like a good image
versus a flexibility versus the weight
his weight is important there you have
to think about like can you really bring
like a bunch of zoom lenses and all that
kind of stuff so I had to learn really
quickly but yeah I've um
it's a whole journey that you've already
been on but it's nice to have a beginner
like me like to explore that I think
there is a
there's a nice thing just I guess we've
been talking about with The Beginner's
mind
to um
not let equipment
get in the way of like what your vision
is of what a thing should look like yeah
sometimes like especially if you're a
professional videographer or
photographer
cinematographer whatever you call it you
can like fetishize equipment too much
you can get so much equipment and I've
interacted that because I've been trying
to learn from other people that have so
much more experience than me
I think their advice is often like
uh very pushing a lot of equipment
versus like
the final thing like how do you create
the art of it and like because to me
even photography is just like
storytelling and so like a lot of the
discussion to me
that I enjoy especially talking to
creative people is like the the final
story like how and I've learned you know
like light light light is a weird thing
like it's so interesting it's so
interesting how you can create emotion
with light like with a little you could
take a
like a phone and like you light your
face in different ways and like it
changes the emotion oh yeah it's so
weird
I'm like holy [__]
like because like that's the
conversation I want to have okay people
give me advice how to light a scene all
that kind of stuff is great but the
reality is that a little bit of light in
a different direction that you have to
understand how that changes the Contour
on your face yeah and everything and the
expression that your face can like the
the expression that could be effective
to communicate under on the different
lighting conditions and then like the
mystery of like having some of your face
uh in darkness and some not uh when you
can only see the eyes and not the face
when the background is visible or not I
mean there's the the yeah it's yeah it's
all just like this interesting art form
that's can be so powerful when you're
telling a story